what's going on realm we're we're back
with another review man attic got you
guys again today we're gonna reviewing
kind of a game that's inspired by dark
souls and games like dead space and i
know that a lot of people don't like
when you compare games to other games
but i'ma do that because that's what i
do uh a lot of this game kind of reminds
me of those games and you know before we
get on with the review you guys know
what i'm about to say definitely hit
that like button if you enjoyed this
review you can always subscribe to this
channel for weekly podcasts we talk
about sports well i don't lord king does
and we have a weekly podcast known as
the iron lords podcast every sunday at
1pm and we have the attic show every
wednesday at 5 pm and don't forget to
follow us all on twitter follow me at
lord addict iop and without any further
ado here's my review on dolmen for the
xbox series x
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming out here
coming at you another video you guys
know i've been trying to pop out these
reviews been trying to play these games
that really interest me and kind of give
you guys an insight on how i feel about
the game uh this game is kind of like
the other game i just reviewed i saw the
set packs and i played this at pax and i
went ahead because i like dark souls
type games and the way the aesthetic i
was looking at when i was at pax this
kind of gave me a little bit of a dead
space vibe as well and it's called
dolmen it's made by massive work studio
all right so let's go and talk about the
story of dolmen dolmen takes place in a
universe where humanity has colonized
several planets and private corporations
fight for military and technology
advantages what's pretty much happened
here is corporations have modified
drillers and what they are is just
humans that are set into
planets to pretty much mine for their
resources and there's these this crystal
called a dolmen crystal which allows the
interaction between different dimensions
and it holds the potential of
revolutionized space exploration so keep
in mind like something like maybe
materials that was made to make the
relays in mass effect where you know
it's extremely important they needed
that to continue to advance the human
technology to go to these places on here
now it looks like at the beginning
there's some kind of huge accident that
happens and it looks like you're some
form of a mercenary that's been hired to
go to this planet called rivien prime or
something like that and you're going
there to take these crystals back and
eliminate all the creatures that are
there and there's a lot more surprises
once you start to unravel the plot story
of dolmen now after playing the entire
game of this i can honestly say that i
was interested in the world of dolmen
and what exactly was going down in
dolmen in this accident what was going
down why he was sent there the creatures
in here i feel like there's a variety of
there but there's not like a whole lot
of lore there and what's sad is when you
get to a really interesting world that
you like in a game but you felt like
they could have put a little bit more
time into making the lore of the game
now i'm not going to sit there and say
that the lord this game is bad or
anything like that and i know a lot of
the issues that's going to come out from
me speaking on this game is going to be
strictly budget-wise but i do feel like
if they make a sequel let's have better
lore let's have better storytelling
let's have you know more cinematically i
i know that that's expensive and that's
not necessarily my fault if it's
expensive but i do understand that a lot
of players when you have these single
player story told games like this
cinematically is extremely important to
really grab people's attention and get
immersion going on and i did feel like
that game was lacking a little bit here
now the villains of the game i was very
intrigued by him when i came across one
as a boss fight it was extremely you
know exhilarating it was a good time to
be in that it's just like look next time
if you guys make another one i don't
think this was it i think you had the
foundation of a story in a world
building where you can make something
like mass effect if you build onto it
now obviously you have a long way to go
before you get something like mass
effect but i didn't mind the story here
now it's like i said they could have
told it better and hopefully if they get
a sequel they make enough money to
full-blown make a sequel on this game
and it kind of looks like they're going
to hopefully go that direction off of
what the story was going about i hope
they do capitalize on this story on the
creatures in this game on what's going
on on the drillers on the main bad guys
in the facility and you know this
mysterious organization that's sending
these people to do all this stuff now
let's talk about the performance of
dolmen i played it on the xbox series x
and look
let me be honest with you guys this this
is a really bad performing game now
clearly i don't know when some of you
are going to come across this that's
watching this on youtube all the stuff
that i could be saying is fixed and i
would very recommend googling dolman
whatever platform you're playing on and
just see what kind of patches they've
had because currently there's a lot of
performance issues on the xbox series x
there's a lot of pop-ups a lot of
stuttering there's a lot of performance
in general going on with this now i did
notice that there's a performance mode
and a quality mode if you go to the
settings on here but i saw the
difference let me let me be very clear
on that i saw a huge drastic difference
in how the game visually looks when you
switch to quality mode but when you
start walking around it feels like a
power point i can't do that so i stuck
on performance mode for the most part
and look did it run bad 100 of time no
but i would say that i myself came
across more performance issues in this
game than i have and probably the last
five or six reviews that i've done now
i'm pretty sure there'll probably be a
day one patch and some of the issues
that i have hopefully will be fixed on
that but like i said i encourage you
guys the performance is huge with you
guys and to a lot of people performance
is everything why do you get a new xbox
series x new playstation 5 why do you
upgrade graphic cards so often you want
peak performance and i do not blame you
guys if you guys want to go ahead and
look on google and find whether or not
the performance was fixed with this day
one patch i wouldn't look past you guys
one bit and i would encourage it
actually it's better to be safe than
sorry now let's let's go to gameplay
because i feel like dolmen exceeds in
game play and false shorting gameplay at
the same time the biggest gripe i have
with dolmen is the slowness that you
feel in this character you don't feel
fluid at all you feel like you have a
pack of bricks that's attached to your
legs now i feel like since the combat is
kind of synth centered around everyone
being slow it's not like the other
people are mad faster than your slow
pretty much for everything everyone is
around the same type of speed depending
on if that opponent is normally a faster
character obviously if you use some kind
of ability to move yourself to the other
side of the room that's different than
just being naturally slow or you're
flying around because there are some
creatures in this game that fly they
would clearly be a little bit more fast
than you but i did notice that when i
played this this speed just didn't feel
right it felt like i was extremely slow
coming from you know sakura shadow dice
twice games and eldon rain to a point
and even you know some of the dark soul
games i felt like this is extremely slow
like this kind of gives me a like a dark
souls one vibe or you know even maybe
demon souls maybe even worse than those
two games in terms of with the the
pacing of the game now it's like i said
those type of games i felt like was
designed to be this slow some of the
bosses when you fight them it feels a
little bit more one-on-one because
everything is so slow and that's
couldn't even be good or bad now i feel
like it's in the middle i feel like if
they make a sequel or hell even with
this game like if any of the developers
are watching this if you can make some
kind of you know
increase of speed patch i feel like this
would go a long way i know that a lot of
people like this type of slow gameplay
but i feel like with the people you're
going to be really going towards was the
dark souls community uh eldon ring since
it just got so popular i feel like
you're going to want to gravitate
towards that type of community and they
generally have went away from the slow
type of gameplay and i'm not saying that
the game plays bad or anything it's
actually a lot of fun when it comes to
when it works but
being so slow i always felt like i was
extremely at a disadvantage and it's a
very challenging game so maybe that was
the whole point but i did feel like they
missed on the pacing and the overall
speed of dolmen now when i was saying
that it was kind of like a from software
game like you know that type of game
play there is a lot of boss fights on
here and i will honestly say that you
guys know how i am with comes to bosses
in general i like
evolving i like evolution i like to feel
like the bosses are kind of going with
the flow not necessarily just fighting
the exact same way and i actually see
this is dolman's strongest suit the
bosses in this game are very difficult
and i'm not saying that they're
impossible to beat or anything like that
i felt like some of the bosses in this
game was harder than anything i did in
eldon ring and that's just because in
this game
you don't have no help you also have
really no consumables or any type of
item to help you really accelerate or
expand your extantimo or you know extend
your health for that matter there's no
accessories to do that either it's just
pretty much you your opponent your
weapon their weapon and you have to go
from there and i like that because a lot
of games especially stuff like eldon
ring they give you summons to help you
they let you do co-op now keep in mind
there is a multiplayer aspect to this
and i didn't really try it because i'm
reviewing the game and i didn't have an
extra person to do that aspect so i
assume that's gonna make the multiplayer
the bosses a little bit easier but even
if you don't use that
it's like i said like there's no
consumables you and the opponent is
extremely slow but i feel like they
always have the edge they always have
that attack that gets you there is some
type of element system in here and sure
i do feel like it has a place in this
game i felt like the whole thing needs
to be redone it's this mo calling it
energy mode and pretty much what it does
is you have elements that your suit can
have you can either have fire poison or
ice and it pretty much engulfs your
whole character in this element now i'm
not saying that this didn't really
matter when playing the game there are
certain enemies that you could clearly
see yo they're fire i need to switch to
ice they're poison i need to switch to
fire i assume that was the weak
disappoints it doesn't really go into
detail it's not a lot of information in
this game i had now i know that is a lot
of the kind of gameplay choices that
these type of games usually have with
the lack of you know information but as
far as like the element mode or yeah i
like to call it the reactor mode because
i feel like that's what it is i feel
like they need to change that if they
make a sequel make it more
important towards the gameplay because i
felt like as long as i was playing the
game properly and i wasn't getting hit
too much that mode didn't really mean so
much to me i do enjoy it and i like the
concept of it it's just like i said with
previous things like they need to really
take this type of gameplay and consider
it a little bit more how they can
interact with the gameplay in general
how attacks and melees can happen how
you know it might be able to change
depending on what thing you do now i
feel like what would be good with this
reactor mode or this element mode or you
know how they should really have it is
energy mode should be one of those
things where if things are going south
it's always that last absolute thing
that you want to do it's that last
resort that when you're about to get
killed you pop that up i feel like your
energy should increase your strength
mobility should increase you go a lot
faster and i feel like that's with the
way they should have went with this and
it really engulfs you an attack because
to me when you went on this it just made
you slightly stronger and sometimes it
would help with certain fighting certain
abilities because when you when you did
this attack you would actually stagger
enemies a lot easier
to be honest with you there was enemies
that staggered in this game but i never
felt like i got a good grasp on how to
make the majority of these stagger it
was always random i know it's probably
not random but for the most part they
probably have ways that you stagger
every one of these abilities and maybe i
just missed something when playing this
but to me the energy mode was effective
but i don't feel like it should have
been effective as it was i feel like
this should have been the core of this
game it should have been what set it
apart from everything else and although
i like what they did with the energy
mode i like the concept next time really
focus on this mode and find out what you
want to do with it so obviously because
this is a souls type game you know the
the gameplay that they actually went
above and beyond to get there's a lot of
aspects of your souls type of games that
you can have in this for instance when
you die you drop whatever currency you
have they call it like a timeline when
you get it you restore your timeline if
you die you lose that timeline and the
timeline is pretty much all the currency
that you've established up to that point
on death now i like this and i think
this is the the standard when it comes
to these type of games but i don't
really have no issue with it comes to
this now i do have an issue with the
stats in general i feel like there's not
enough information on the stats look i
don't mind you
information hoarding me when it comes to
certain aspects of the game like how the
element system works or you know
generally information on the enemies and
tactical things where if you figure out
what element they're weak to but when it
comes to your stats look man massive
work studio go ahead and give us some
kind of help system on what every one of
these stats do obviously because i've
played these type of games before i
could pretty much you know strategically
figure out what each one of these do and
they do kind of give you a little bit
information but it's just like i like in
an elderly ring when you click help it
tells you individually what all of them
do and how they help you and i felt like
that kind of information needed to be on
this game and another thing there's an
equipment system on here and there's an
actual you know crafting system on here
and it's actually a decent crafting
system there's boss things that you can
get where if you defeat a boss you're
able to get their weapon and you know
the interesting part about the boss
mechanics in this game is like i said
the boss fights are spectacular i
honestly say that's the highlight of
this game by far and you know what's
even more of a highlight than amazing
boss fights the ability to fight them as
many times as you want that resource i
was talking about domain resource you
get that throughout throughout the game
fighting and killing enemies and you can
take that resource and if you get a
certain amount of them you could go back
to that boss room and interact with some
kind of system or some kind of computer
in front of it or go back to your ship
and do it there where they're all there
and you can actually respawn that boss
and fight them again and keep in mind
the boss fights do have a form of
multiplayer in it so you can fight them
hopefully with another person like i
said i didn't get to do the multiplayer
thing with another boss but i think
that's interesting because the funny
thing how the crafting system works is
every boss has like a boss weapon or
maybe armor i didn't really see all of
them i saw a good amount of them but i
don't want to put out any definites i
don't know if there's armor that
belonged to any of the bosses but pretty
much the only way to get that weapon was
to go back and fight the boss again and
some of these bosses like i said they're
very difficult you have to really learn
their patterns and they punish you for
not learning them correctly sometimes
you'll be doing very well and you mess
up one time and that kills you a lot of
the bosses in this game have instant
kill stuff and what i like about this
game is they let you go ahead and fight
these people they give you crafting
systems to get better weapons and they
reward you for going out and fighting
them again
you know conquering that boss again and
i like that i just felt like there
should have been more information with
the crafting system if i wanted to i
should have been able to look what the
crafting materials were now sure you
could see them when you pick them up and
i think that's pretty apparent on that
but i tried to the best of my ability
and you know maybe i missed it where i
was just trying to see what is that
material that i need to make that armor
or to make that weapon and it wasn't
letting me see and it was it was very
frustrating because when you need
something like that it's very obvious
when you can't see you don't know where
it came from i'm not telling you to tell
me where these you know materials were
out in the wild but i at least would
like to know what they're called instead
of just having a picture up at the top
and you know speaking of equipment
there's a lot of different variety of
ways you can play this game you can play
more of a long range character you could
play with a heavy weapon you can play
for sword and shield you can really play
the way you want to play and i love all
this but i did feel like some of the
equipment was worth more than other
equipment now i did have a
shield i don't know if it was any good
or not but the shield kind of seemed
useless on here and part of me wanted
just to do well but when i went to try
to do it it wouldn't let me do well now
i do know that there is a sword that you
can grind for to do will by defeating a
certain boss multiple times to get the
currency or the material whatever you
guys want to call it off of him when he
drops and you can use that to make this
weapon and i like the fact that some of
these weapons are really stat based like
you need a certain amount of skill or a
certain amount and um what was the the
energy you need certain amount of energy
to wear some of this armor and i like
the way you do the armor as well where
you need the last piece of armor to
upgrade it to another tier but i felt
like that whole crafting system maybe
just a little bit more information on
how it works and maybe a little bit more
information on you know the crafting
system in general like i didn't know
that you can upgrade an armor to another
tier just by using the last one or i
would have done it a lot sooner i went
through half the game maybe even more
than half the game not knowing that
going out there with a default armor and
that was a very frustrating time maybe
that's the reason i thought the game was
very challenging is because i did have
that disadvantage on myself and you know
i i i'm not going to say that the the
crafting system was horrible it's just
like i prefer if you give me more
information and maybe give me like a
charismatic person that does it for me
when i talk to him i hear like some nice
little dialogue or something there's not
a lot of dialogue in this game and to be
honest with you the sound in this game
is kind of absent in general i feel like
they really need to work on that i feel
like you know between the the feeling
you get when you hit someone and the
sound of hitting them could be a done a
lot better and i'm not saying that you
know they they lacked in this entirely
because some of it was there but a lot
of it wasn't and i feel like they need
to really focus on that maybe in a patch
or a sequel or something now look pretty
much what i'm saying about dolman made
by massive work studio is this game has
a lot of issues and it's kind of like a
from software game that doesn't really
know what it wants to do and it does
everything okay but nothing fantastic
and i think that when it comes to these
type of games you want to do at least
one thing great and i feel like they did
a bunch of things okay would i recommend
buying this game i mean probably not
because there is a lot of performance
issues i feel like some of the systems
didn't work correctly but one thing i
will say is the boss system and the
difficult of the game in general is kind
of unique i've never really played a
game like this and it is one of the
hardest kind of from software games i've
played even some harder than some of the
from software games themselves now i'm
not going to say they all were harder
but i will say that some of the boss
fights in here was on another level than
anything i've ever seen in some of the
from software games i'm saying if you
like a challenge then i would say this
would be worth your money you know maybe
if you don't like a challenge you want
to see exactly if they fix anything in
the future like i said a google search
is one step away man search dolmen
patches on all the platform whatever
platform you have i think this is on
xbox playstation it's probably on pc as
well so definitely look up that i've
always told everyone that goes to need
to be more educated on when you buy
these games make sure you don't buy
something that's broken now i'm not
gonna say it was broken on playable or
anything like that it wasn't i felt like
the game functioned correctly for the
most part but there was a lot of
performance issues and i felt like some
of the gameplay was lacking there
because i don't really think that they
you know knew exactly how they wanted
some of these features to work and i'm
not saying it was bad it's just like i
felt like they need to look at this
stuff if you make a sequel i hope this
game selves well enough to you know
justify sequel and someone will be able
to greenlight a sequel because the
foundation of this is fantastic i feel
like this studio the only difference
between them and someone like from
software is a budget i feel like if they
hire more animators to make the
animations better more graphic designers
to make the the world pop out more fiber
i think it would be a lot better than
what it is now now i'm not saying that
would ever compete with anything like
from software i think that's still a
couple games away and to my knowledge
this is one of the first games if not
the first game that massive work studios
made so that's probably phenomenal right
there to make something uh no maybe not
this quality because the quality isn't
exactly there but you know something is
fun as this is when if you like these
type of gameplay i wouldn't recommend
buying this if you don't like from
software games you're probably just
going to waste money at that point
because i do think that that is the
overall best aspect of dolman is the
difficulty in the boss mechanics of the
game and just have the boss feature in
general sometimes you'll have three boss
phases on something and i like when you
do that when you change things up on me
i really enjoy something like that it's
like i said the story is okay we just
need it told better the performance is
horrible i would say horrible it's just
not that good you know it's probably
gonna be better at the day one patch but
i don't report off day one patches i
report off when i played it off and i
played it and the performance was up and
down all the time gameplay was good but
it needed to be a lot you know
overhauled a lot in the aspects of the
gameplay and the music was pretty much
not existent i didn't there was some
bosses that had good gameplay music but
i felt like they could have really
improved on that and a lot of that comes
down to budget this stuff costs money
and i don't know what kind of how many
people was on dolman how many people
works at massive work studio but what
they did and for the amount of people
that i assume is not going to be a lot
did on this game
i like what they showed me and i feel
like there is a lot of potential in this
foundation of this game called dolmen
and like i said when i was doing the
story thing the way they kind of ended
this game makes me think there's going
to be sequel if it gets greenlit i don't
know if it's going to get green left we
don't even know the sales game's not
even out yet but anyway tell me what you
guys think the comment section below is
don't been you know really interesting
you guys i'm kind of curious on this
it's not any form of like subscription
service like game pass or playstation
plus but if it does come on to those
services in the future i do think it's
worth a downloader it's forty dollars
and like i said if you're real big fan
of souls type games you wanna challenge
definitely worth the 40. i myself
wouldn't recommend it i would say just
wait till a lot of these performance
issues gets fixed and even after that
like i said some of the gameplay is
really lacking here but they got a good
foundation and i think if you guys
really enjoy these type of games and you
want to encourage you know the evolution
of this type of genre go out there and
support it man i think you would enjoy
the game itself especially if you like
to use souls type games you know it's
like i said if you don't like sales type
games stay away from anyway that's the
review on dolman for the xbox series x
made by massive work studio i appreciate
them for the code man they really showed
us love over there at paxtees and until
next time this is gamey addicts until
the next review i'm outta here peace